c'est pas plutôt clic c'est jusqu'à un
moment donné vaut mieux que je le dise
moi même avant que les gens ne s'en
rendent compte
car oui je vous le dis je suis un mytho
et si vous êtes observateur vous verrez
que quelque chose a changé ici là et pas
autour de moi non ce n'est pas mon
nouveau disque dur ce sont mes lunettes
référence 8 me choque fut rien référence
à la vidéo que vous verrez la haye et
j'ai enfin des lunettes et deux oui je
peux vous le confirmer
je suis aveugle chez aveugle monga
depuis que je suis petit je ne savais
pas en fait c'est pour ça que je suis
dans mon monde je ne voyais rien et j'ai
su ça une fois que j'ai mis des lunettes
j'ai fait à [ __ ] c'est vachement bien
fait la réalité c'est fou quoi tu vois
la définition et tous ces incroyables et
c'est pas grave je n'ai pas besoin de
voir pour faire la vidéo bon alors
pourquoi je suis un mytho bas on va en
parler tout de suite après le générique
[Musique]
comme vous le savez en ce moment je suis
en tournée et de spectacles ça veut dire
je pars de bill envie de faire des
spectacles et surtout ce qui est
intéressant c'est qu'on se voie après
qu'on discute quelque chose mais
beaucoup revenu c'est aussi quelque
chose que je lis dans les commentaires
depuis janvier 2016
et ouais mon pote sadate et que je
reçois par mail par facebook par twitter
instagram snapshot et in de l'une de ces
informations est fausse bon cette
fameuse question que vous me posez
souvent c'est comment est ce qu'on fait
pour devenir mentalist est ce que faut
acheter des livres de mentalisme ou
faire des formations mentaliste mais
aujourd'hui j'avais envie d'y répondre
en prenant mon propre exemple un
mentaliste
mesdames et messieurs est un mythomane
j'ai bien conscience qu'en dix ans à se
dire je suis un mytho épais voile à
allier c'était un proc depuis le 1er
janvier 2016 tout ça n'existait pas que
des complices en fait c'était toujours
le même conflit dans la vidéo mais qui
se maquillent très très bien qu'à vous
avez eu l'impression de voir à mixer vos
pires crasses par exemple c'était pas le
but est toujours la même personne c'est
ma soeur ma soeur fait tous les
complices hashtag choqué les supp
bon alors pourquoi je dis que je suis un
mytho parce qu'il n'ya personne qui va
délivrer à quelqu'un en france ou en
europe ou dans le monde
le statut de mentalist officiel ça
n'existe pas pour la simple et bonne
raison qu'ils a pas de définition du mot
mentalist ça veut dire que tous les
mentalistes que vous verrez que ce soit
sur youtube en spectacle à la télé etc
ce sont les gens qui comme moi moi le
premier se sont levés un matin en disant
je m'auto proclame mentalist c'est le
mot que je vais utiliser pour me définir
ce qui veut donc dire par extension que
chaque mentalist a sa propre définition
à plus ou moins de nuances ou parfois
avec des grands fossés ce qui explique
aussi que parfois je vous vois vous
prendre la tête dans les commentaires
quand je lis parfois quelqu'un qui dit
oui mais non là il n'a pas lu dans ses
pensées donc il est pas mentaliste et
que l'autre lui dit non mais s'il a
déduit ça ça ça donc c'est sale du
mentalisme est ce que c'est bien clair
tout ça oui
ma définition je vous l'avais déjà donné
une fois dans une vidéo de l'année
dernière donc on était bien moins
nombreux qu'aujourd'hui mais pour vous
la donner rapidement pour moi le
mentalisme mon point de vue qu'il n'est
pas meilleur ou moins bon que celui d'un
autre mentalist c'est un mélange
deux techniques de déductions qu'elle
soit psychologique de lecture non
verbale tout ce genre de choses qui vont
nous permettre de déduire une
information qu'on cherche toutes les
techniques d'influencé que ce soit du
simple force h le psychologique à un
ancrage psychologique a peut-être de
l'hypnose conversationnelle tout ce qui
va me permettre en fait d'influencés un
choix là dessus je sue poudre
allègrement de techniques de
mémorisation comme vous avez pu le voir
sur la chaîne mère la chaîne ressemble à
ma définition technique de calcul rapide
où on va dire d'une manière générale
d'une gestion plus optimums optimale de
saint-servan de techniques de
prestidigitation qui vont permettre
parfois d'essayer quelque chose et si on
se rate
on a quand même une sortie de secours
qui sera plus faible est moins joli que
ce qui était prévu au départ mais qui
permet de retomber un minimum sur ses
pieds au niveau de la dignité et puis là
dedans il ya détournement d'attention
aussi par exemple qui est intéressant
quand les psychologique et enfin d'une
manière globale le fait d'essayer de
comprendre comment fonctionnent les
choses d'une manière générale donc une
espèce de curiosité exacerbe donc ça
c'était ma définition donc c'est comme
ça que je pratique mon mentalist que ce
soit dans les vidéos sur scène au
quotidien en allant chercher le pain si
demain je rencontrais quelqu'un qui est
juste en écoutant le bruit que fait un
moteur est capable de dire ou es ce qui
est située la panne dans la voiture et
qui dit aura chez lui chemin ta liste
chez mentalist carrossier et ben ils
auraient tout à fait le droit ce qui me
permet de vous emmener maintenant à
l'objet ultime de cette vidéo c'est que
je vous les conseille d'acheter de
manière générale des livres neufs des
mentalistes en deux jours en 2h10 ou des
formations pour devenir mentalist là
aussi encore une fois attention disque
les mains je dis pas que ces livres là
sont bien ou pas bien je les ai pas
forcément lui de toute manière tu ne dis
pas qu'ils n'ont pas un bon contenu je
n'en sais strictement rien votre
définition et vos attentes seront
peut-être pas celle qui a dû tout dans
le livre exemple très concret un jour en
achetant un livre de mentalisme qui
était fort intéressant au demeurant j ai
trouvé un lit quasiment consacré aux
palmes reading à la lecture des lignes
de la main alors c'était passionnant
parce que je connaissais pas ça et et ça
me plaît toujours en fait d'en savoir
plus dans ce domaine là qu'on y croit ou
pas en fait c'est pas le problème c'est
toujours le problème c est ce que je
peux découvrir autre chose et essayer de
comprendre pourquoi ça fonctionne
pourquoi les gens y croient mais tu vois
entre ma notion du mentalisme et les
de la main il y avait quand même un
fossé que vous voyez ce que je veux dire
définissez vous même qu'est ce que le
mentalisme pour vous et dans cette
définition vous allez dégagez des grands
thèmes comme moi je les fais tout à
l'heure et sur ses grands thèmes vous
allez pouvoir aller plus vers la lecture
des micro-expressions par exemple ou sur
des livres de référence sur la mémoire
comme les livres de tony buzan dont je
vous ai souvent mis les liens dans les
descriptions par rapport aux vidéos de
mémoire vous allez pouvoir composer
vous-même en fait votre propre chemin
propre formation voilà
écoutez je vous fait de tenir une petite
ordonnance vous vous faites à like de
vidéos avec peut-être un petit
commentaire qui fera plaisir vous me
faites ça une fois par vidéo pendant un
mois et ça se passera bien vous pouvez
vous abonner comme d'habitude et rendez
vous très bientôt extrêmement bientôt
peut-être même demain
on voit prêt demain en fait j'ai un gros
montage à finir là pour vous je voulais
de sortir aujourd'hui
moi c'est pas du tout bon aujourd'hui
donc demain ou après demain ciao
[Musique]